翻訳: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
人はそれぞれ大切にしていることがあります
ポリシーとか モットーとか
座右の銘とか 言い方は色々ある
多分 中身も人それぞれ全然違う
僕の場合はこれです
[黄色い封筒をめぐる冒険]
誰もやっていなくて
誰も頼んでいないけれど
誰かが望んでいるはずのこと
これに全力を注ぐ
これが 僕が一番大切にしていることです
じゃあ一番好きなものは何か
もちろん「カレーライス」です
この２つを一緒にしてみる
一番大切にしていることを
一番好きなもので 実行してみる
するとここから
ほんのささやかな冒険が始まります
僕がカレーを好きになったきっかけは
ここ 生まれ故郷の浜松にあった
一軒の「ボンベイ」というカレー屋さんです
永田さんという人がやっていました
僕はここに小学校１年から
高校卒業するまで通い詰めた
もう食べて 食べて
とにかく食べまくって
今思えば 結構いいお客さん
(笑)
気が付いたら僕はカレーという料理[の]
虜になってたんですね
だから永田さんは
僕に与えた影響はすごく大きい
誰かの人生を決定してしまうような
強い影響力を持ったカレーシェフ
実は彼だけじゃなくて
全国各地にいます
これって すごいことです
石原さんというシェフとの出会い
それから別れにも影響を受けました
彼は横浜の「ガネーシャ」という
お店をやっていた
僕はこの店が大好きだった
石原さんのインドカレーに対する情熱は
尋常じゃなかったんです
僕がお店に行くと
必ず僕のテーブルの横に貼りついて
ずーっとカレーの話
永遠に終わらない
でも僕は楽しい
そんないい関係は
長くは続きませんでした
2007年 彼は癌でこの世を去ります
僕は訃報を聞いて 言葉を失いました
同時に 頭の中では別のことを考えてた
石原さんみたいなカレーに人生を捧げている
シェフが全国にまだまだいる
もっと多くの人に知ってもらいたい
じゃあ僕は全国のカレー店を訪ね歩こう
こんなことは誰もやってません
誰も頼んでません
でも 知りたがっている人がいるはずだ
じゃあ全力を注ごうと思ったんですね
早速取材に行きます
１軒目は埼玉
小森さんというシェフに
いろいろ話を伺いました
「いつカレーと出会ったのか？」
「どこでカレーを学んだのか？」
「どうしてカレー屋をやろうと思ったのか？」
「実際にやってみてうれしかったことは？」
「つらかったことは？」
「今 カレーとはどんな
気持ちで接していますか？」
「これからカレーを携えてあなたはどこへ
向かっていこうとしていますか？」
初めのうちは戸惑いがあります
そりゃそうです
いきなり押しかけて行って
僕は根掘り葉掘り
でも何度も足を運んでいると
だんだん心開いてくれるようになる
僕は小森さんが残してくれた
数々の面白いエピソード
一冊の本にすることにしました
文庫本サイズで20数ページぐらい
ちっちゃな本です
僕はこの本をまずは
全国のカレー屋さんに
届けたいと思ったんですね
さあ どうやって届けましょうか？
ここで黄色い封筒が登場します
今どき封筒で手紙を送るなんて
そんなアナログなこと
流行んないですよね
だってメールがあって
インターネットがある
でも僕はこれがいいと思った
「幸せの黄色い封筒」
これが日本全国のカレー店に届く
妄想を膨らませます
素敵だなっと
自己満足かな
これ この封筒 どうして黄色いか
「あっ カレーだから黄色にしたな」
と思った人 結構いたんじゃないですか？
別の理由があります
実はこの色が一番 値段が安かった
（笑）
百枚セット買いました
全国 70軒の カレー屋さんに送ります
挨拶状を添えて
「初めまして こんな封筒 こんな本
趣味で作りました
ぜひ読んでみてください」
「ちなみにこの封筒は
今日 今回初めて送りました
でもこれを送るのは
これで最後だと思わないでください
これから新しい本ができる度に
僕はこの封筒を送り続けます」
ちょっと脅迫状まがい　（笑）
僕が勝手に送りつけた封筒は
当然ですが
無事 全国のカレー屋さんに届きます
どんな反響があったと思いますか？
僕はすごく期待していた
全国各地で拍手喝采
「よくやった！」
でも 現実は全く違いました
僕は封筒を送ったカレー屋さんに
カレーを食べに行きます
すると シェフがこんなことを言いました
「水野くんさ あの黄色い封筒
あれ一体 何のためにやっているの？」
「いや あれはライフワークです
シェフのこと皆に知ってもらいたくて」
「それだけのため？」
「そうです」
「本当に？」
もう懐疑心たっぷりという感じ
「そんなことして
君に何のメリットがあるの？」って
何か僕は 不当に疑われているような
気持ちがしましました
別のお店に行きます　すると
そのシェフはまた別の事をいう
「あの黄色い封筒のあの本は
どこの出版社の企画？」
「あ あれは僕の企画です」
「またまたそんなこと言って
どうせそのへんの本屋さんで
そのうち売り始めるんでしょう」
「いや そんな予定ありません」
「本当に？」
僕は結構ショックだった
全力を注いでいることが
完全に空回りしている
それでも僕はこの封筒を
送り続けることにしました
２通目 ３通目
これじゃまるで「幸せの封筒」どころか
「不幸の手紙」　（笑）
仕方がないですね
僕は頑張って送り続けるしかない
あるシェフに電話をします
取材を[させて]もらいたい
お願いの電話です
ところが そのシェフからは
電話口で断られてしまいます
「いや〜 うちはいいよお金払えないから」
僕は取材先から
お金をもらってこの活動やってません
むしろ 交通費も宿泊費も
本の制作費も全部自腹でやってます
この安売りの封筒だって
これを送るための切手だって
自分で買ってやってるんですね
それがシェフたちには解せなかった
当然 僕だって
自腹を切るのが素晴らしいなんて思ってない
他にアイディアがなかったんです
もし 僕がこの封筒で お金を儲けていたら
みんなは納得したと思います
でもお金がかかることを
好きこのんでやる
何で？何のために？
なんか怪しいんじゃないの？
裏があるんじゃないか？
そう思われるのも 無理もないかもしれません
それでも僕は封筒を送り続けます
結構性格がしつこい
（笑）
４通目 ５通目 ６通目
ドキドキしますか？
僕は送りながらすごいドキドキしていた
大丈夫かな？
でも 全力を注ぐと決めたんです
簡単に諦めるわけにいきません
すると 少しずつ
周りの反応が変わってきました
嬉しいことが
黄色い封筒に返事が来るようになった
「シェフの生き様に感動した」とか
「面白かった また次も待ってます」とか
こんなお店がありました
「お客さんが全然入らない
もうそろそろ店を閉めようと思っていました
でも全国には自分よりも苦しくても
頑張っているシェフがいる
勇気をもらった このお店は
もうちょっと続けてみたいと思います」
図らずもこの黄色い封筒は
そのお店の救世主になりました
僕の友人があるカレー屋さんに行きます
するとこんな会話を聞いたと言いました
「ポストを覗いて黄色い封筒が
あるを見つけると嬉しくなる
毎日頑張って仕事をしていると
神様がご褒美をくれる
そんなふうに感じています」
これ 作り話じゃないですよ
本当の話
か、神様？神様
ちょっと言い過ぎかな？
でも嬉しい—自慢したくなる
まぁ だからここでこうやって自慢しています
（笑）
このシリーズは 号を重ねていくうちに
黄色い封筒の数が増えていきます
今 この封筒のシリーズは
合計16名のシェフたちを取材してます
彼らの半生は
すごく
素晴らしくて 特別なものばかり
こうやってみてください
見てると 顔だけ並んでいると
なんかただのおじさんって
感じもするかもしれない
ちょっと街中であったら
声かけられたくないなぁみたいな
怖い人もいますよね
（笑）
でも この人たち
皆んな カレーに人生を捧げている
すごく素晴らしいシェフたちばかり
そんな彼らのお話はすごく面白い
例えば富山県の早川さん
彼は東京のある老舗のカレー専門店の
味に惚れ込みます
惚れ込みすぎちゃって
とんでもないことを始める
その店の創業者に 内緒で
そっと富山に帰って
全く同じ店を作っちゃいます
外観も ロゴもお店の名前も
全部一緒（笑）
考えられますか？
僕は信じられない
そんなことやったら
お父さんやお母さんに怒られます
でも彼はそのあと
熱意を創業者に伝えて
のれんをもらって
支店として 営業を続けています
ドラマのような現実の話
大分の瀬口さん
彼は—
いい顔してるでしょう？
この時はお酒ずいぶん飲んで
酔っ払っています（笑）
彼は 東京の２軒の
有名なインド料理店で修行を積んで
もう超がつくぐらい 腕のいいシェフです
でも 大分でカレー屋を始めて
お客さんが思うように集まらない
家賃も十分に払えません
実に８年間
彼は苦しい思いをしました
いいですか ８年間ですよ
彼は何をしたか？
毎朝早朝に 新聞配達をしながら
家賃を払って 店を続けました
気が遠くなるような話
この穏やかな笑顔の裏側に
不屈の精神が隠れていました
何人も取材をしていくうちに
この黄色い封筒の数は
どんどんどんどん増えていきます
封筒の数が増えるということは
本を読んでくれる
カレー屋さんの数が増えるということです
70軒で始まったのが 今 150軒以上
梱包作業がけっこう大変
でもそれは嬉しい悲鳴です
むしろ 嬉しくないこともある
送った封筒が
そのまま戻ってきてしまうことがあります
これは 理由は宛先人不明
つまり
カレー屋さんがもう閉店してしまって
シェフは居所がわからなくなった
好きなカレー屋さんに会えなくなるのは
つらい現実です
さて 黄色い封筒をめぐる冒険は
ひとつ 新しい段階に入ります
シェフ同士がお互いの店を
行ったり来たりするようになりました
そのうち飲み会が始まります
僕も呼んでもらえるようになりました
あこがれのシェフたちが集まって
僕もそこに入って
お酒飲みながら カレーの話をする
生きててよかった
（笑）
大袈裟だと思います？
飲み会の参加シェフはどんどん増えています
５名、10名、15名
多いときは 20名近く
のぼることもありました
これはカレーの世界
あまり横のつながりがなかったこの世界で
この黄色い封筒がつないだ
新しい人間関係です
そこで僕はひとつの提案をすることにしました
「こんなに多くのシェフが
集まってるんですから
せっかくだから
テーマを決めて研究会しませんか」
「あ いいね やってみようか」
すべてのシェフが賛同して
研究会が始まります
テーマ 例えば「タマネギの炒め方について」
２時間 ３時間
議論が止まりません
次のテーマ
「スパイスの投入する正しい順序について」
２時間 ３時間
もう変態の集まりです　（笑）
でもこの研究会 もう20回を超えて
今 現在も続いています
そのうちまた新しい提案があった
「せっかくこれだけのシェフが
集まってるんだから
店を年に１回休んでみんなで
イベントやったらいいんじゃないか！？」
「いいね！」
カレーのイベントが始まりました
シェフが渾身の料理を集めて
一皿に盛り合わせて 提供するイベント
研究会というすごく
閉じた空間で行われていたことが
日本全国のカレーファンが楽しめる
イベントに成長しました
[黄色い封筒が成長する]
黄色い封筒が めぐりめぐって
いろんな人の間に
コミュニケーションを生んでます
これは１通目を送った時には
全く想像できなかったことです
このささやかな冒険は
これからも成長を続けることと思います
もう僕にはどうなるか分からない
何が起こるのか
どこまでいくのか
だからそれが楽しみです
一方で僕は
新しい封筒を 探し始めてます
誰もやっていない—
誰も頼んでない でも—
誰かが望んでいるはずのこと
きっとカレーの世界には
まだまだいっぱいあります
誰もやってないから やる前は不安
誰も頼んでないから
やると 不審に思われる可能性もある
でも どこかで 誰かが
望んでいるはずだと思えば—
そんな確信が持てたら
その活動は 絶対に
続ける価値があります
次に僕は見つける封筒は
もう黄色じゃありません
青いかもしれないし
赤いかもしれない
場合によってはバラ色になったり
虹色になったりするかもしれない
「虹色はちょっと言い過ぎ でしょ!?」
って思う？
だったらマーブル模様でも水玉でもいい
とにかくそんな活動が—
ちょっとでも面白そうだと思ったら
皆さんも封筒を 探してみてください
僕はカレーでやります
皆さんは？
もしカレーでやってみようと思う人がいたら
僕と一緒に新しい封筒を探しましょう
（拍手）